hi I'm Steve Carell and I'm Kristen Wiig
and we are about to take the wired
complete interview is that what it is
you have to give us that again the wire
I can just leave it okay is Steve Carell
Steve Carell young at heart hurt but not
anymore
but yes I am cuz you know what I think
being young is a very subjective term
and I feel fit mm-hmm
I feel healthy I do look great and I
think that's really more is Steve Carell
and first of all that's not proper
English are we related are you related -
no well one of my best friends is her
brother daily show together oh no I do
have a connection okay did Steve Carell
Canadian nope I am from Acton
Massachusetts is Steve Carell actually
good at skating I am I actually played
last night and I got a bruise on my
finger cuz I caught a puck with my glove
bet I bet it looks cool it did it's
Steve Carell a vegetarian no miss Steve
Carell Italian I am my family name was
carousel II which means wild horses
apparently all right is it your turn who
does Kristen Wiig look like I don't know
I don't know thankfully that's not a
question I can answer you don't look
like anyone because you are unique
Thanks you are a one-of-a-kind thanks
when they made you they broke them all
you are a national treasure
who is Kristen Wiig exist er I do not
have a sister who is Kristen Wiig
Despicable Me well I play Lucy is that
the question I am not at liberty
I think people hear about Despicable Me
and hear that
in it and then they google who was
Kristen Wiig who is Kristen Wiig it's
best friend my boyfriend and you
whoo-hoo-hoo that is
I feel like who that is Kristen Wiig
okay these are the best question I've
ever been asked in my life okay
who they is Kristen Wiig shirt if you
have you John that's who they is Kristen
Wiig shirt which is shirt wearing I am
theory okay here we go right what
Steve Carell like in real life he's the
nicest person that I've ever he's super
what Steve Carell real yes deep girl is
my real name
what does Steve Carell look like what
movie are Steve Carell and Ryan Gosling
in Crazy Stupid Love and Big Short what
is Steve Carell favorite color blue how
to pronounce Kristen Wiig how do you
pronounce Christian it's wig but
technically wig is Norwegian and it
would be weak but it's like how was
Kristen Wiig discovered SNL was my first
big job does that count
yeah yeah how's Kristen Wiig get on SNL
I auditioned how about you get Kristen
wigs hair funny you should ask that I am
starting a wig line to imagine okay it's
where Steve Carell go to college Denison
University where's Steve Carell General
Store Marshfield Hills Massachusetts my
wife and I own a general store where is
Steve Carell right now someone googled
back
that's a little creepy right now we're
in a hotel in Florida where does Steve
Carrell vacation I like to visit
Massachusetts work from what Kristen
Wing what does Kristen Wigg say in
Spanish bridesmaids
oh I'm just I think I see something
about a library I don't know I just kind
of put words together
what does Kristen Wigg first NL episode
Oh Jason Lee and the Foo Fighters were
on my first episode
what does Kristen Wigg eat you know let
us read oh you like that no we have to
put bread on lettuce and sometimes I put
lettuce lettuce on bread what Kristen
Wigg character are you that's a real
deep question what character do you
think people most identified the target
lady I don't know either okay well that
was the dumpee
wired autocomplete interview mm-hmm I'm
sure you're gonna watch it again right
now
the one question I have for all of you
is what Kristen Wigg eat shirt it's
something to ponder